[music]
>> Point number 21.
Those who excel in the international
Dawah training program would not be
given a certificate of participation,
but would be given a certificate of
excellence.
There's also a separate certificate
known as certificate of excellence, and
there is no fixed rule
that there's only one certificate or two
or three.
If all 20 are good, inshallah, all 20
will get.
If 10 are good, 10 will get.
If three are good, three will get. If
none are good,
none will get.
Because we have a standard that if you
get a certificate of excellence,
you have to reach a certain level.
And inshallah, I pray to Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala
that if not all, at least most should
get.
Inshallah.
Last point, amongst the excellent
participants, there will be a ranking
given as per their performance.
So, if five people get a certificate of
excellence, there'll be a grading,
first, second, third, fourth, fifth. If
two get, first and second. You know why?
Why?
Why not everyone gets a ranking?
Logically, everyone should get, right or
wrong?
Yes, brother sir.
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykum as-salam
wa rahmatullahi My guess is that those
who get the certificate of excellence,
in your humble opinion, will be ready to
deliver the
Dawah on international stage.
Any other answer?
No, I believe, inshallah, all all who
complete the course would be ready.
Yes, brother Arshad. As-salamu alaykum.
Wa alaykum as-salam wa rahmatullahi Um I
think because we don't want to
demotivate anyone, but motivate people
with
the the reward. Let's put it that way.
It's positive reinforcement.
>> Don't want to demotivate anyone, want to
motivate.
Yes, brother.
Because for example, if there's a race,
so everyone does not get a ranking.
There's only first, second, third. So,
there has to be certain importance given
to certain people who have strived
harder as compared to the rest of the
people. So, those people who have got
excellent certificates, of course, they
will be on a different level as compared
to the other people.
Yes.
So far the best answer, but not hitting
the nail on the head.
Yeah, those who got excellent are
better, we know that. Yes, brother. Come
with me.
As Jannah have rankings, so you are
giving some rankings for Alhamdulillah.
Yes, that is there, but why?
Why not the ranking?
Most importantly, I believe you want to
choose the best of the best.
Correct?
>> Yes, that's it.
>> the best get the excellent, that is
fine. So That's why I give the
excellent, but why give ranking only to
excellent and not to the non-excellent?
The ranking on the excellencies
maybe
they will be under you,
then you know where to send them. Maybe
the difficult parts of the world, you'll
send them a one. The reason is number
one,
that when you get a certificate of
excellence
says
that you are a good guy.
Not getting doesn't mean you are not,
but it's a certificate from us that
inshallah you have performed very well
in the training program.
Whether you're good or not, Allah knows
the best. We cannot comment. It's Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala who's the best to
judge.
You have performed very well, and the
chances
that you will be able to deliver are
very high.
So, that differentiates between a person
who gets a certificate of participation.
He participated. He was there in body
for sure.
Maybe in mind and soul also. What level
we don't know. Or he strived hard a lot.
He achieved a lot. He may be able to
convey the message 10 times more.
But, when you get a certificate of
excellence, that means you have come up
to the standard of Islamic Research
Foundation or Peace TV.
You know, it has a standard.
Now,
hypothetically, no one does good.
Hypothetically. And then if I give
first, second, third,
you will like I got first.
You understood?
First,
let's become effective dies.
International Dawah Training Program
conceived, planned, and developed by Dr.
Zakir Naik. I came out first.
Now, if he doesn't get a certificate of
excellence, getting a certificate of
excellence is more important than coming
out first.
Getting both together is the best. Do
you understand?
If I say a person came out first without
certificate of excellence, that means
it's Andon Mein Kana Raja. In Hindi we
say, in our language,
that he's a cockeyed king
in people who are blind.
It's a saying in Hindi.
It doesn't sound that well when I
translate it. That a person who is a
cockeyed becomes a king
if he's living in a people
who have no vision.
Andon Mein Kana Raja means people are
blind and the person who is a cockeyed
becomes a king.
So, certificate of excellence is the
most important.
Even
if 10 people get
and the person comes out 10th,
it's much better than not getting
certificate of excellence and getting
the highest marks. If the marks are
given, suppose, and hypothetically, no
one gets certificate of excellence, and
we come to know,
okay, brother Abu Shahriz got the
highest marks.
Hypothetically.
He should not be happy. Why? Getting the
certificate is more important than
getting highest marks.
Andon Mein Kana Raja. Or maybe out of
20, 15 get
and he comes out to be the 15th.
He should be more happy than
not getting certificate of excellence
and coming out first.
Even though it will not be announced who
is first, when the marks will be
announced you'll come to know
approximately who's first, second,
third.
So, getting the certificate of
excellence is more important.
And from the certificate of excellence,
the person
who get the highest would be mentioned.
So, if five get, we'll say first,
second, third, fourth, fifth. If 10 get,
we'll mention first, second. So, again
you can say, "I came out fifth in this
training program."
So, getting the certificate of
excellence is most important.
Do you have any questions?
Yes, brother Zakir.
During the training, can I can we
address you as Zakir Bhai or sir or
which is the best way to address you? I
personally don't like anyone calling me
sir. I don't like it. It's not haram.
It's not haram to call anyone sir, but I
personally don't like anyone referring
to me as sir.
Normally, I'm more commonly called as
Zakir Bhai, which is in the language of
India, means brother Zakir. Or in Arabic
you say Akhi Zakir. That's what I
prefer. Though I know some of you may be
very young.
Unless otherwise, you know, because my
son is older than you, cannot call me
brother.
But otherwise, generally, if people just
call me brother Zakir or a person who's
elder to me calls me Zakir also, there's
no problem at all. And I don't think so
anyone is elder here. I mean, elder is
brother Kamruddin.
And he's younger to me, alhamdulillah.
Just for information, I've just crossed
50 years.
So, if you can refer to me as even
brother Zakir or Zakir Bhai, no problem.
That no problem at all. My question,
Zakir Bhai, is that
this is a training program and we have
very strict timings. But we are quite
nervous because this is the first of its
kind of training we are attending
mashallah.
If we have questions or we don't
understand certain things because the
desire to learn is very high and we are
not that
I mean polished background in terms of
that one memorization and so on. If
there are certain things you teach us
and we don't understand we don't have
the grasp. Can we interrupt and ask you
to repeat and
or how does it go or do we meet in the
break and ask you those questions if we
don't understand do we go about it? That
we'll discuss in the rules and
regulations.
But if it's a lecture.
Where notes are not given to you it's
like a lecture.
So don't disturb the faculty.
Let him finish. If you don't ask note
down during the question and answer time
you can ask that when you spoke about
certain thing about technique I couldn't
understand about the gesture please
could you repeat? No problem. Or if you
have any question. If it's a point form
note like the one that we had.
In this session. After every few points.
The instructor will give you time.
Or even if he doesn't give you time you
can raise your hand because of the point
form note. So either he will tell you
ask the question or he will tell you
wait.
For another few minutes. So if it's a
point form note you can raise your hand
in between also.
Normally the instructor gives time after
every few points. But even if you raise
your hand in between there's no problem
at all.
He may tell you just wait or he will
tell you okay what's the question?
So don't wait for the break please.
Break time is not for asking questions.
Because the instructor may not be
available.
Yes you can discuss amongst yourselves.
The participant should not discuss among
themselves during the.
Sessions. In break time you can discuss.
But if you have any question the best
time is to ask during the session.
Unless.
The instructor feels that a person is
taking too much time. And the time is
getting short. I mean because of lack of
time.
Then he may tell you, "Okay, we can
discuss maybe in the holiday or in the
rest day, etc." Hope that answers the
question. Jazakallah khair. Waiyaka.
Yes, brother. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullah.
My question is that when asking
question,
can we ask while standing or sitting?
That's my question, sir.
While asking a question, if you're
seated,
you can remain seated and ask.
If you're on the stage and if you ask to
perform and take a question, that's not
a different.
So, if you are seated, no need of
standing.
I mean, that is a formula done in the
Western world.
And if it's the rule of a session, but
here it's not required at all. When
you're asking a question, you can be
seated and ask a question, there's no
problem at all.
That is the best.
Assalamualaikum. Walaikum assalam
warahmatullah. Uh I have two questions.
Uh one is that on the rules and
regulations of this international that
was training program, it was stated that
the points and of notes will be given to
all participants for every of the
sessions. Yes, most of it
is 80% of it. So, would it be possible
is that the notes of the next day
sessions be given earlier in order for
us to go through it so we have a better
grasp of it, better understanding of it.
That would be my first question. And my
second question would be on the point of
the 19th point where every day each
participant will be evaluated and the
major criteria and was stated in one of
it is that surprise.
What does it mean by surprise? Thank
you. The first question is
that if the notes are given in advance,
then they can grasp better. What we want
you to do after the session, we'll give
you homework.
Whatever has been done after hearing and
the notes, you'll grasp better.
Imagine, suppose you don't know
medicine.
And if I give you how to do surgery,
what will you understand?
And if you start doing surgery on the
notes, you may take a patient and kill
him.
You understand?
So, here,
the best is paying attention when the
instructor is speaking.
Now, if you read the notes
and you jot down certain points, the
mind normally is only focused on that
point. You'll forget everything else.
It may be a point form note.
He's going to speak 10 times more than
the notes.
Because you're focusing on that, the
best is when the instructor speaks.
See to it that you listen to him
attentively.
According to me,
jotting of the points in the point form
notes requires a very small percentage
of your time. See, most of you are
mostly listening to me. That's what I
like.
So, the notes, if given in advance, will
defeat the purpose.
Yes, when you come here,
if it is a point form note, we give it
to you so that we can be on the same
wavelength.
And what question you have,
you can note it down on a notepad and
ask immediately.
Because
when I'm saying maybe five points in
sequence, the note form only gives one
line for the first point. The
explanation five lines.
Many a time, the explanation is covered.
And if you don't understand the first
point correctly and go to point number
two, and if you read, you may not
understand the second point.
So, best is with the explanation,
you listen.
And if there is any difficulty, ask
during the session itself. And there
will be homework given to you.
So, when you leave the auditorium,
there'll be a couple of hours homework.
There was a homework given to you
about 2 weeks in advance.
That memorize
the 114
names
with meanings of the surahs of the
Quran.
>> [screaming]
>> Muhammadun [music]
Rasulullah.
Arjuda kaya
Anta Rahim ya
Habni [music] ataka ya
Anta Karim
Minkal atao ya
Antal alimo ya
Fika rajao ya
Antal Halim
>> [music]
>> Ar-Rahmanur Sattar
Malikul Mulk
Wahhabul Mannan
Ar-Rahmanur Sattar Malikul Mulk
al-Ghaffar
Wahhabul Mannanul Muta'al